hello freak [ __ ] when you can get
through it if you can get through 15 of
those in 30 days I think you can [ __ ]
get through a lot of [ __ ] but I think
you surprise yourself I think you're
totally right and the amount of
discipline it'll you'll need on two
fronts is great but here's the other
thing you're such a fun here's the last
one real stakes what does that mean well
there is stakes man like you get you
lose your beard listen you had somebody
oh yeah past you for what happened with
its BMI is it's a measurement of the
height and weight yeah I said okay you
have to height he's clearly lying about
his height so just stop [ __ ] measures
hi I'm six
after you right now for enforcing
negative stereotypes your voice breaking
like you went to Asia for four months we
cannot reach him
he's like that bet really yeah I was
five times Parkin duas duty to me
weren't they enjoyable to go oh my god
you for real now the first 15 to 20 days
outs [ __ ] angry at you guys for
telling me I was a well sure these
[ __ ]
I got a [ __ ] calm down Sam well I
don't feel like I said you were I tried
to stay I really don't I try to
but the fans wouldn't have it I like it
like that when they did somewhere and
ooh we good yeah we're good
I want every member being somewhere and
then I was like someone's like Bert you
look skinny and and someone goes Thomas
fat and I go yeah I go what we I go so
there's you don't know that we had a bet
going and someone yelled Ari's a Jew
paper towel maybe I shoulda told the
story later no did you stop thinking
about it
have you blocked it out how bad it was
center stage and told that story was
that where's that worse than the laugh
lounge how would you feel what I mean
that would be my worst story ever that
would be that would lower the standard
would you feel like about yourself would
you be like did I have a seizure like
what yeah wrong I'd be like I drink too
much I'm super fat my story
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]